welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
Daniel batsman a professor of history at
Yale University and the chair of the
Council on East Asian Studies at the
Macmillan Center he teaches courses on
the history of Japan from 1,500 to the
present his publications include a
translation of the memoirs of a
prominent post-war foreign minister
okita Saburo a life in economic
diplomacy and a study of the history of
punishment from the 16th to 20th
century's punishment and power in the
making of modern Japan today we talked
with Professor batsman about his
research paper titled freedom without
slavery coolies prostitutes and outcast
in May J Japan's emancipation moment
welcome professor Watson Thank You
Marilyn let's begin with an overview of
your paper and its premise so one of the
things that I've been interested in for
quite a long time in a general kind of
ways the feeling that a lot of people
have that there's a fundamental divide
between the west and the non West and
one of the things that I think is in
that kind of general view of the world
supposed to set the West apart is the
idea that the West loves freedom that
freedom is the supreme value of the
Western world and that again is kind of
always put in contrast with the
non-western world mm-hmm and that I
think is a pretty commonplace idea but
one of the scholars that's really taken
that idea and briefed on it in an
interesting way as a sociologist named
Orlando Patterson who want a lot of big
prizes for a book he wrote about the
history of freedom in the West and what
he argues is that the reason that the
Western world has embraced freedom in
this very special kind of way actually
has to do with the history of slavery in
the West and that without the very
particular relationship
that the Western world has to slavery
you wouldn't have this embrace of
freedom I say and those two things
struck me as interesting things to think
about those two propositions that
freedom is something that really is
uniquely embraced by the West and that
that also is connected to the history of
slavery those things seem to me
something that could be usefully thought
about in the context of 19th century
Japan which is what most of my own work
focuses on and the reason for that is
that first of all 19th century Japan was
a place where freedom really is embraced
and becomes a kind of central part of
political discourse in especially in the
decades following the major restoration
of 1868 calm so that's the first thing
and then the second thing is that Japan
at that time is also a society where
slavery as an institution really does
not exist at earlier points in the past
there had been something like slavery
but most scholars agree that by the 18th
century or so slavery is pretty much
disappeared from Japanese society so
here we have a non-western society that
embraces freedom and doesn't have
slavery so I was interested in working
out you know what the case of Japan
might have to say then about these
bigger issues and what I conclude in a
kind of general way is that the idea of
slavery does become very important in
Japan in that period is a kind of
metaphor for talking about lots of
different groups in society who needed
to be set free so once these groups are
identified as slave like then you can
also start introducing this idea that
they need to be emancipated and that in
turn i think paves the way for a kind of
broader adoption of the rhetoric of 19th
century liberalism in japanese political
life ok and how did you come to write
the paper well as you mentioned I wrote
a book that took a long time about the
history of punishment ok which had lots
of lovely
you know things in it you know various
gruesome torches and horrible ways of
executing people and then also the kind
of exploitation of prison labor and so
on so pretty grim stuff so part of me
wanted to do something bright and
cheerful well what could be happier than
freedom sure the reality of course was
that probably because of faults in my
own personality freedom also turned out
to be a fairly grim topic in many ways
because it's very hard to talk about the
history of freedom without then facing
the reality that it's usually the hopes
that are invested in this idea of
freedom usually end up getting betrayed
so so anyway that was one of the at a
kind of personal level that was one of
the things that got me interested in the
question and then you know I'm a
historian so I like to put things in
kind of broader social context the other
thing that was happening when I started
thinking about these things was
Operation Iraqi Freedom and you know
that really led me to think about the
way freedom as a general concept gets
used to excuse or justify all sorts of
things which may or may not actually
have to do with concrete practices that
really enhance freedom in people's
everyday lives okay and in working on
the paper how did you do your research
well that was a lot of fun so for one
thing there was a really wonderful body
of secondary literature about the
history of slavery freedom that was
great to kind of dig into but then in
Japan I was able to go through all sorts
of diplomatic records old newspapers
various kinds of archival materials
things to do with history of
prostitution and the other thing that
was nice about it is whereas most of my
earlier work involved really focusing
only on materials written in Japanese
because of the particular moment that I
was investigating in this paper I was
able to draw on a lot of things written
in other languages so obviously
other things in English but also there
was material in Portuguese in Spanish
there was even materially and Russian
and French so there was all sorts of
interesting angles as I dug became
apparent so that was that was fun okay
and one of the the central parts of your
paper is the maria luz incident and then
a subsequent emancipation edict so tell
us about that a little bit because
actually I thought that was pretty
fascinating that trial yeah so that's
really the the core of the papers as you
say so the maria luz incident basically
involved a ship that had set out from
Macau and was headed to Peru and it gets
caught in a storm in the middle of the
Pacific and one of the masts on this
ship is snapped and so it limps back
trying to find a porter friendly port
where it can weigh anchor and and make
repairs so the port that it ends up in
is Yokohama and soon after the ship
arrives in Yokohama and the captain
request permission to make repairs men
start jumping overboard and swimming to
neighboring ships basically begging for
help and this of course leads to an
investigation you what is going on with
this ship and and of course it turns out
that the cargo on this ship is human
cargo specifically indentured Chinese
laborers or [ __ ] laborers who are
being taken from Macau to Peru to work
in plantations and actually guano mines
and so on there was actually that
fascinated me because I had no idea
about Peru would would do something like
that so that came as a surprise to make
and again what time period are we
talking about so we're really talking
about the early 1870s and peruse
involvement in the so-called Pacific
Cooley trade spends a couple of decades
it's a kind of on-again off-again thing
but at least in english-speaking world
Peru comes to be identified with the
worst abuses of of this Kali trade which
very quickly particularly in post-civil
war the United States very quickly comes
to be identified as a kind of new slave
trade and that of course that's the
scene for what happens in Yokohama too
because once it becomes clear that these
men who are jumping overboard [ __ ]
laborers who are being held on this ship
against their will there's mounting
pressure on the Japanese government to
do something and eventually a trial
takes place in fact two trials and and
it hasn't I mean it's definitely an
international affair which right also I
found very interesting right because at
this point basically the Western powers
don't trust Japan to behave responsibly
in legal matters and so the court that
is convened in fact is as you say a kind
of very international court where there
are American and British advisers
working with the Japanese judge and
where the opinions of all sorts of legal
advisers from different parts of the
world who have been brought to Japan to
advise the government are are involved
so again going through all of that
material and the multiple layers and
arguments that were kind of being laid
out both in public and behind-the-scenes
was really interesting but I mean the
trial is actually the two trials are
quite complex but really in the end the
key thing is this comes down to a
question of is this a form of slavery if
it is what is Japan stance and in the
end the Japanese judge issues a
statement saying this is clearly a form
of slavery Japan will not tolerate
slavery and he cites a couple of
interesting precedents for that which
had to do actually with attempts by an
American businessman to try and recruit
Japanese workers to go to Hawaii
and that has in the years preceding the
maria luz trials kind of created a bit
of a panic in Japan especially amongst
Japanese elites about the possibility
that Japan will become the focus of a
new Pacific slave trade right okay so
the idea that Japan might be pulled into
this new kind of slave trade in the
Pacific has already kind of taken root
so anyway the judge in the case the
Murray lose case says Japan will not
tolerate slavery and so these men should
be set free basically and that has all
sorts of implications right for Japan
what were the implications right so one
of the things that happens in the
context of the trial is that both people
within the Japanese government and
various members of the expatriate
Western community in Yokohama start
talking about start debating the
consequences of this issue and one of
the things that they both groups very
quickly point to is the situation of
prostitutes in places like Yokohama
where basically the establishment of
red-light districts and brothels was
something that Western diplomats had
pushed very hard for because they
thought we're going to have all these
sailors coming into port and they need
women basically otherwise they're going
to run amok so as a result of that
pressure and then partly also because of
Japan's own history of kind of
establishing these kinds of districts in
any urban center you do get a very
flourishing prostitution business
established in Yokohama and the women
who are working in the brothels are
actually held under contracts which are
very similar to the contracts that are
binding the [ __ ] laborers on this ship
even though they couldn't understand
what they were assigning them when they
sign them right exactly well i think in
both cases you could say that the same
thing yeah well the women in
the brothels were often too young to be
recognized as legally responsible so
that meant their fathers would sign for
them great yes a lovely lovely story I
know and in the case of the Chinese men
on board the ship there's all sorts of
evidence that they were kidnapped often
and then forced to sign or that they
didn't understand the documents they
were signing but so there were these
very clear parallels between these two
sets of people so what did japan do so
in the end japan issues an emancipation
edict for prostitutes and entertainers
soon after the maria luz trial and i
think one of the things that's very
interesting about that is that when you
look at the debates that were going on
within the ranks of the Japanese
leadership prior to this they were very
conscious of Lincoln's Emancipation
edict and developments with the
abolition of slavery in other parts of
the world so this is an example I think
where you get this kind of global
phenomena of kind of emancipation of
slaves having also these very concrete
local consequences and again you know
both the prostitutes and the coolies on
board the Maria lose their position is
slave like but I think there's real
difference between their situation and
that of you know those who were
basically and what will a dull slaves
well for one thing these contracts were
not permanent they expired after a
certain period were they actually
honored yeah I think yeah yes people
were released if they lived long enough
okay I mean so it's obviously not kind
of wonderful arrangement but it starts
to give you a sense I think of how you
know the question of what exactly is a
slave what is slavery it starts to
expand a little bit especially in a
context like that of you know East Asia
which has a very different kind of
history to the Atlantic world with
regard to these things
so the idea that kind of the slave
becomes a metaphor that can be applied
to different groups and then once you
identify someone as a slave I think then
it kind of becomes automatic that you
start thinking about the need to freedom
mm-hmm and I think that is exactly the
process you see playing out in Japan the
other twist in all of this is that you
know historians have often actually
dismissed this emancipation edict
prostitutes and not paid very much
attention to it and the reason for that
is they've often seen it as a kind of
sleight of hand or a kind of publicity
stunts and and that is because you know
this emancipation it ends these
contractual arrangements that it existed
in the past but it certainly doesn't
bring an end to prostitution and instead
what it does is it really puts the onus
on individual women to say i am going to
become a prostitute and so the
conditions under which they're working
and the circumstances in which they're
held are actually often more or less the
same as what they were before the
Emancipation edict but instead of this
contract being something that's entered
into by the family it has to be the
woman herself expressing the desire to
work as a prostitute so it becomes a
kind of matter of individual agency or
one could say I mean once you become a
prostitute wouldn't it be very difficult
to then become something else if you did
not wish to be one well that's actually
a very interesting question and one of
the things that people have often
observed about prostitution in the late
Tokugawa period in Japan is that there
was much more flexibility with regard to
kind of moving out oh really then so you
weren't branded a prostitute forever you
were able culturally to make your living
doing something else yeah that's one of
the general things that people often say
about prostitution in the 80 period so
the stigma
having been a prostitute was not as
great as perhaps it was in contemporary
Western societies but they do have the
history of but it was terrible work and
a lot of people died you know syphilis
rates were and so on were extremely high
so yeah okay so what do you conclude in
your paper so the kind of lost twisting
at all is that a few years prior to this
case another emancipation edict had been
issued in Japan well actually I'm
getting ahead of myself an edict was
issued which took Untouchables okay no
which is not something that most people
associate with Japan right you think
India exactly so that's actually part of
a bigger project I'm working on but
there were untouchable communities in
Japan and soon after the major
restoration before the maria luz case
there's an edict issued which basically
promotes these Untouchables to the same
legal status as ordinary commoners how
did that go over well that's a very
interesting question in some parts of
the country there were riots okay um
that this was a terrible thing so
basically in the same way you had brace
riots protesting you know the kind of
so-called phenomena of uppity black
people off to slavery was abolished the
same kind of thing happens that you know
you these uppity Untouchables
interesting how human nature is so very
similar no matter where you go in the
world yeah it's true and if you think
about I mean one of the things of course
that makes untouchability so interesting
is that it really defies our assumptions
about who gets discriminated against
because these are people for whom there
are no markers of ethnic difference
there's no religious difference you're
born into it you're absolutely born into
it some people were able to get out and
pass as commoners but most people stayed
within these very poor generally very
poor communities so
but in spite of that very big difference
the history of say african-americans
post emancipation in the United States
and these untouchable groups in Japan
post this emancipation edict is very in
kind of similar again it's a very long
and hard process of really claiming a
kind of full array of civil rights and
it's not until the 1960s and 70s that
you really get substantial changes so
even at that level there's some
interesting parallels but what I was
going to say about how this all connects
back to the maria luz case is that at
the time that the untouchable groups are
kind of promoted in status there's no
kind of invocation of the language of
liberalism of freedom of emancipation
it's just a kind of promotion and why do
you think that is why does the promotion
happen you know why do you think the
freedom the idea of freedom and the
wording that would accompany that would
not was not part of that that they were
just promoted right basically because i
think this edicts that promoted them was
coming out of an older discourse and
oldest set of ideas about how society
needed to change which was really part
of a kind of discussion that had been
happening within japan and hadn't yet
meshed with these new ideas that were
being introduced from the Western world
and so what happens in the wake of the
maria luz incident is you get people in
government saying oh and we've already
had a kind of emancipation edict already
for the outcasts so in other words you
get the freeing of the coolies then you
get the freeing of the prostitutes and
then you get this reimagining of this
earlier act to kind of promote
Untouchables as again an active
emancipation and now if you talk to
people in Japan about the Meiji period
emancipation edict no one remember
was this formal emancipation edict for
prostitutes what they do remember is
this earlier edict which freed the
untouchable groups interesting and so
tracing the history of how that kind of
reimagining in terms of the language of
liberalism happened is something I'm
also interested in very good well this
has been fascinating thanks so much for
being here with us today thank you for
more information about professor batsman
and his research please visit our
website at yale edu slash macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you